نحن نستخدم عدد كبير من المسرات واغلب
التي نستخدمها في عملياتنا هي طائرات
نتحكم بها عن بعد ام كيو 9 ونحن نستخدمها
لعده اغراض في المنطقه وكما ذكرت اغلب
استخداماتنا لها خاصه بمكافحه الجماعات
المتطرفه العنيفه
وقدره هذه المسيرات على التحليق فوق تلك
المناطق لفترات طويله مفيد جدا في هذا
السياق نحن في القوه الجويه التاسعه نسعى
لتوسيع استخدام التكنولوجيا غير الماهوله
والرقميه فمن ناحيه امن الحدود ومراقبه
نشاطات تهريب فان مثل هذه المنصات التي
تحمل المجسات وامكانيه تحليق لفترات طويله
تمثل اداه مهمه للغايه
[موسيقى]
واستطيع ان اقول لك ان شبكه الاكتشاف
والقدره على اطلاق الطائرات المقاتله
لاعتراض المسايرات القادمه واداء قدرات
الدفاع الصاروخي لدى العديد من الدول من
شركائنا مدهشه حقنا ولذلك فان تعاون الذي
نشهده عبر الحدود بين الدول ذات المصالح
المشتركه ضد هذه التهديدات التي تقدم بشكل
اساسي الى شركاء ايران مثل الحوثيين في
اليمن فهذه الامكانات واعده جدا لجمع
الدولي ذات المصالح المشتركه
[موسيقى]